My name is Sarah Perry.
I'm the author of the novel The Essex Serpent
which this series is based on.
I felt very strongly that I wanted to hand it over to somebody that I trusted
and I have confidence in Anna and in the production company.
She has been incredibly generous in allowing me
to make her amazing book work for screen.
The most important thing when adapting is to keep the soul of the book.
It's really beautifully written.
It's a wonderful adaptation of the book.
Anna had retained so much of Sarah's novel
but she'd also added something as well.
A lot of interiority.
With a screenplay you don't have the luxury of so much description.
You have to fold the depth into the characters actions as opposed to their words.
There is this feeling of handing something over
and saying "I trust you completely."
My first instinct was right
that they knew exactly what they needed to do with it.
Should we walk?
It’s so exciting to see your work brought to life on film.
Sarah Perry has been very generous
in allowing us to take the series to some different places.
I am here to be an extra.
We are filming a scene at the Natural History Museum
where Will Ransome unexpectedly meets Cora.
This is a scene that isn’t in the book.
It sort of achieves two things I think.
It enables Cora and Will to have an additional form of meeting
but also really importantly it shows Cora
as somebody who is deeply interested in paleontology.
Very at home in the Natural History Museum.
It’s been really amazing and actually quite uncanny
to suddenly be living inside of one of my own imaginary worlds.
What Sarah Perry did so brilliantly in the novel
and we have tried to bring to life
is that all the female characters are so unexpected.
Nothing about their behavior is
fitting this stereotype of victorian, subservient
constrained female.
Sarah managed to create characters that are completely of their time
but also strikingly contemporary.
You’re furious because I didn’t ask your permission!
Even now, Cora Seaborne is described as a modern heroine
and she is absolutely not.
She is as educated and as independent
and as socially aware as 19th century women were at the time.
Well if we were welcomed into professions then we might have vocations too.
I couldn't agree more.
The most challenging aspect of any adaptation
is just trying to achieve a series which people who loved the book will love as much.
But also, for people who haven’t read the book
to fall in love with it in its own right.
The demand I suppose was for us to be brave enough
to meet Sarah where she started.
One’s imagination can take all these different shapes and forms
and live on beyond even what I had imagined it would do.
It has been a joy to see.